um but bringing it back to the actual uh
argument um does anyone know what gender
dysphoria actually is yeah it's a mental
uh
i won't say deficiency but
that's what i do but
yeah yeah i remember watching somebody
who's a transgender woman describing
what it was so according to the nhs i'm
going to read it out right so it says
gender dysphoria is a term that
describes a sense of unease
that a person may have because of a
mismatch between their biological sex
and their gender identity
this sense of unease or dissatisfaction
may be also
so it may be so intense that it can lead
to depression anxiety
and have a harmful impact on daily life
so that's according to the nhs
right
so
gender dysphoria
is an unease according to
you know the the the nhs it is a
an ease of
feeling something
so my question is when it comes to
transgenderism
is it a feeling
yeah
i would say so yeah i believe so i
wasn't feeling sorry
because um otherwise why would someone
choose to just
switch to the other sex right they feel
something that is and that's making them
feel and easy in their own skin
otherwise they wouldn't have just
changed it right why would they just go
through that whole trauma going against
whatever they feel as nature right and
then go through like go through comments
harsh comments for no reason they are
feeling something that is making them go
through that transformation right so i
would definitely believe it's a feeling
of unease that's making someone take
that decision or maybe a drastic
decision of just transforming it so when
did so my whole question now becomes
when did a feeling
trump reality reality
social acceptance i i
i
i don't i agree with the question that
sounds so weird i agree with that
question because the the thing that's
coming in my head is that there has been
children as young as 12 13
really push forward on getting their
gender changed or sex changed and it's
like
is that okay is it okay for someone as
young as 12 or 13 to come out and say
yeah i'm changing my sex i'm going to
identify as someone else where does that
feeling begin um
yeah but i feel like i feel like i feel
like if if you feel like your feelings
if somebody feels like they are that
they they identify more with the
opposite sex i don't have a problem with
it that's how you feel
i don't have
if that's how you feel that's how you
feel you know like if you wake up and
you feel happy you feel sad you feel you
know whatever and if there is a means to
achieve whatever it is you feel then go
for it but
when it comes to kids like you said you
can't allow kids to
say how they feel and then act on it
because
the kids you know i'm trying to say but
if it's a fully grown adult and you know
exactly what what you want from your
life
and you feel like you're you identify as
a woman or a man or whatever it is i
feel like there's nothing wrong with
that
um if sorry if it keeps persistent for
example so if their kids and they're
still growing the feeling keeps
persistent then there's definitely
something wrong right yeah if the if the
and like if the uneasy feeling keeps
growing inside them
yeah then when you're an adult when
you're an adult then you can do whatever
it is if there is a means to achieve it
i feel like i think if you break it down
into this though it's it's it's syncing
between what's in your mind and your
body yeah now the question is and this
is just fundamentally the issue
if there's
something out of sync between your mind
and your body mm-hmm did we treat the
mind or do we treat the body mind yeah
mind your body yeah right now
treating the body trust me but really
the mind
you see like for example there is a i
can't remember the exact um
mental condition it is but there's
people that are fully abled but they
identify themselves as crippled they're
called trans able thank you thank you
and they want to literally amputate
their legs yes did we allow that to
happen as a society yes if someone's
yeah
they want that yes because that's where
the site is going i don't agree with it
but that's what society will do they
that's society are attending to
uh
in this days and times they are saying
because you feel a certain way we are
going to accommodate your feelings okay
and so
because you feel this way
the if somebody feels like if a man
feels like a woman or a woman feels like
a man
the
what we are going to do we are not going
to treat you mentally we are going to
change your physical so you feel better
about yourself
and that's what society's doing yeah put
that intolerance
there's nothing wrong with that hold on
because if women can get boob jobs and
get lip fillers and stuff like that
what's the brush where's the light
seriously
if if a woman feels like she wants to
enhance how she looks she can if a male
wants to he can peter andre with his
enhancements whatever it is
what is the difference
i can give you a difference um the
difference in this scenario is uh
transgender
the actual movement is affecting society
and not just the individual themselves
so if a woman gets a boob job as such
right that's a something that you could
say necessarily it's for herself and yes
it may have imp impacts on other people
but it is effective to say yeah
do you think that kim kardashian's
job affected just herself or did it
affect a society no that's like on the
bra no that that's true that's true
yeah it's true but we we can choose to
view her content whereas with the
transgender movement
i can't choose not to play someone in a
sport yeah is a biological male
um yeah because they identify as being
female i just think yeah but sorry sorry
go ahead sorry i just think there must
be a line drawn somewhere like
you're telling me a man nowadays can get
pregnant
hold on i think the line has to be with
terminology because if like i said if
you're if you're a man and you want to
transition to a woman that's fine but
you can't participate in biological
women's sports so you can do what you
want but and where you said it affects
society
society shouldn't allow those
individuals to affect society
essentially because allowing a man to
participate in a biological woman sport
because you're now a transitioned woman
it doesn't make sense what a lesson
sorry what
alexa just said right
was
segment is segwaying me onto what
congressman
congressman dan bishop recently said
right they were in congress
right and there were two medical doctors
sat down and he asked the question
what is a woman
to a medical doctor right and the
medical doctor says
whatever you identify as congressman dan
bishop
said
can a man get pregnant and have an
abortion the medical doctor said
yes yes
the reason why i saw this and the reason
for this is is fear
medical professionals literally
um because of their backlash they
literally have to
medical professional knows what they
said is bs but they realize if i say the
truth i'm going to get a backlash on
social media so i have to lie which
explains to you why
um totalitarianism can happen because
you're scared of the consequences if i
speak the truth i'm going to lose my
career and then rather people are more
more comfortable with comfortable lies
than the harsh truth sorry you were
saying sorry go on jesse this is
congressman from um america's dan bishop
awesome okay i thought so uh yeah yeah
it's
uh come back to me because
you were gonna you were gonna say
something you were saying your mind is
blown yeah actually because um it's just
something like maybe i can i could say
against the natural you know if if like
a doctor actually says that just imagine
how many people would just
react to it i mean i'm just talking from
a perspective of my own ethnicity right
like if you go to an arab country and
just say that yeah a man can get
pregnant now and can choose to do
abortion two things that is very
controversial in an arab country people
just lose their minds you know
it's important to understand the context
of that conversation the context was he
was in a courtroom yes
under like testimony on oath and he had
to give a statement that would have had
direct implications on his job no no dan
bishop was a congressman asking the
medical doctors a question there were
two female medical doctors okay and he's
female female medical doctors
okay and he asked the female medical
doctors
what is a woman so that's even worse
yes
so women are now saying we don't know
what a woman is and he asked the woman
can men get pregnant and have abortions
she said
yes
wow that's the thing exactly that's what
context creating you know using words to
look it up folks
congressman dan
bishop right okay go on go on youtube
and look up
um congressman dan bishop okay and see
what happens you will see the female
medical doctors say yes
it's sad because
those two questions are very simple easy
questions to answer but the fact that
i feel like common sense amongst people
across the world has gotten less and
less yeah that should be just a common
sense answer a woman this is what
a woman you need to be a woman and then
no a man cannot
have a get pregnant or
get an abortion because it's physically
impossible there's just nothing yep yeah
but it's not no it's not i don't think
no it's not men can get pregnant the
doctors are responsible men can have
periods they can't oh
no as per today's society because
is so fresh i had mine yesterday i just
come off
i'm pale you see you see so you know i
can have my back listen respect my
pronouns okay see you could if
technically if you did transition
and
and you were still
biologically
a
female but you identify as a man that's
where you can say yeah i'm a man i can
still get pregnant and uh have a period
but it's just like
biologically you're still a woman and
that's where do you think the goal is
yeah i think the issue is i think it's
it's
it's definitely that the doctors don't
know what they're doing it's cowardice i
agree they they're scared of the
backlash but we've had that across the
whole pandemic as well yeah people yeah
they're scared of they're just scared of
if i say the truth now i'm gonna lose my
job i'm more afraid hence why we will
believe you know like i said sweet lies
than the harsh truth but it for but not
for a fact if she was in the operating
theater she's gonna be very very black
and white this is a male this is one
needs to give the smell this is a female
this one needs to keep this female
there's not going to be no transgender
argument because if you give a female
dose a male dose to a female body that
person could die and even differently if
you commit a crime and you leave your
dna at the scene of the crime they're
not going to be like oh
they're going to be like oh this was a
man at the scene of the crime because
but right but she identifies as a woman
is that and imagine you were in court
you were like that can't be me because
i'm a woman yeah
that's not my dna it only adds
yeah so how confused that you were
saying what's the end goal
i don't know i mean i'd love to know the
answer because it seems to me there's a
connection between politics and business
and i've not quite worked out how this
is profitable
because
nobody no one that i speak to about this
thinks this is normal yes yeah when you
turn on the tv yeah it's portrayed as
normal yeah by these people speaking out
though are they scared to speak out
because they lose their jobs because
they've got mortgages to pay like when
when you see some like especially the
trans demographic they say they're
underrepresented they're mistreated
they're not accepted in society
you can go to any government building
over the next month and you'll see
rainbow flags yeah i've seen
rainbow flags zebra crossings i've seen
rainbow flag police cars even raleigh
vanessa which is not exactly you know
like the most liberal of places
to be fair with you yeah it's a very
conservative county
um
there's rainbow police cars and i'm
looking at going how much did that cost
for you guys to be wrong yeah you know
for real like how much does that cost
you to spray the cars or get the vinyl
stickers i don't know what it is but
like why are you doing this because the
police is not there to make political
statements it's there to be impartial it
should be it's not anymore
but then where is the where is the
political advice who's this who's
funding it exactly but also and what's
the final result of it is it i think
personally i think the final result is
to make the society more weaker so even
though we know it's wrong but we realize
if we speak her we can lose there's
going to be big consequences well yeah i
mean if you think about it if you if
what cyrus said earlier on about men
transitioning to be wounded
and it is mainly men doing it
there aren't any real men left around to
stick up for the rest of society you
know it goes back to that alpha moment
what do you mean real men what's a real
man yeah one of a penis
i'm not afraid to say that
i'm not afraid but it's true yeah you
kind of get it's like
the beta tization if that's even a word
of society
you know because you get like you said
men aren't afraid aren't allowed to
speak up if you speak up you lose your
job i've known political commentators
and people that are on youtube people in
america politicians that have lost
access to their bank accounts because
they've said the wrong thing at the
wrong time in front of the wrong person
and it's gone around the internet yeah
they've got no money now they can't make
no money yeah they can't have access to
their bank they can't pay their bills
that's not fair yeah
and you haven't you haven't permeated
society in schools as well
where children are being suspended from
schools for saying
what's the transgender bit i don't i
don't get it
we're actually gonna we're actually
gonna get into that